it's the most expensive thing you own
most expensive thing I got three expense
my dogs because they cost a lot because
I had to pay for a lady to go fly to
Madrid to Moscow from Moscow back to
Madrid Madrid to L.A and I had to pay
enormous sum of money just to get the
dog in the hospital he's at the vet
costing me three grand a day and he's
been there for six days he'll be fine
he'll be fine I can't wait to get back
on Saturday to finally see him dogs are
family so I get it they absolutely are
that's why they're so expensive I don't
really look at like a watch or anything
like that things that have a little bit
more meaning which is my dog